you are watching Al jazer and we take
you live to these pictures from outside
Al shiffer Hospital in Northern Gaza
where snipers around that hospital have
been firing
continuously the hospital once again
under bombardment as we've been saying
for several weeks now Al shiffer has
become very much a center for many of
the civilians in Gaza to seek uh
Refuge you can see the explosions there
lighting up the night sky the hospital
even prior to this latest bombardment
was on a knife edge in terms of a
shortage of significant Aid It's Been
Under Fire at least five times in the
last 24 hours it has for the Israeli
military been regarded as something as a
focal point uh for their ongoing
military operation they have repeated
claimed that it is a location where
Hamas Fighters are based without
substantiating those claims in any way
what we do know however is that large
numbers of civilians continue to regard
Al shifer as a safe space But as you're
seeing here by these images clearly not
all right